[Musik]
ich finde aber die sieht auf jeden fall
so aus wie eine pizza die man im
restaurant auf dem teller bekommt der
zuzug darauf sagt man wer oder das sup
darauf ist auf jeden fall gut erholt als
gedacht
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video
ja und ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
heute gibt es mal wieder eine neue folge
von food neuheiten essens neuheiten wie
man möchte
es kam er insgesamt schon drei teile
dazu wir hatten einmal essen generell
dann hatten wir getränke neuheiten und
süßigkeiten neuheiten also alles
irgendwelche erstens produkte die
2009/10 erst auf den markt gekommen sind
an die es jetzt noch nicht kennen also
darum geht es heute und ich habe unter
den letzten videos zu diesem format die
ihr euch auf jeden fall anschauen sollte
sehr oft gelesen alex mal bitte die
neuesten pizza neuheiten habe ich jetzt
in der 16 minute neu gesagt also darum
geht es heute ich habe ein bisschen
recherchiert es war diesmal verdammt
schwer
dennoch habe ich vier pizzen gefunden
die als 2009/10 erst auf den markt
gekommen sind und die schauen wir uns
jetzt erstmal an
hast du übrigens es gibt ja jetzt jeden
tag um 19 uhr in hier auf diesem kanal
ein neues video stellt euch immer
schönebecker und eigentlich auch immer
mit kameramann heute fühle mich
allerdings sowohl mit stativ weil der
kameramann ist gerade im urlaub nehmen
es mir nicht übel mit kameramann ist
eigentlich besser ok als erstes haben
wir dr oetker pizza traditionell corvo
format kam am 16 mai 2009 10 auf den
markt habe ich noch nie probiert aber
noch nie gesehen deswegen die tester
heute also wie name schon sagt da ist
ziemlich viel käse drauf an sich stetig
auf diese zu viel ist dann allerdings
auch nicht nice also wenn zu viel käse
auf pizza ist dann bin ich raus und der
krise muss aber gut schmecken
manchmal ist da ja so gehse drauf da
kann man sich nicht sicher sein ob das
im endeffekt wirklich mal käse war also
die tasten wir als erstes danach ich bin
wirklich mal extrem gespannt das ist
eine pizza würde ich mal sagen aus dem
premiumsegment von gustavo gusto habe
ich noch nie probiert ich habe
allerdings von vielen leuten schon
gehört dass wenn man sich so eine pizza
kauft und die macht im backofen das
schmeckt original wie als wenn man ins
restaurant in bildern
dort eine frische pizza bestellt das
hier ist eine vegetarische pizza mit
baby spinat und schnittfestem mozzarella
hat glaube ich knapp vier euro kostet
und wenn ich hier diesen spruch schon
lese da bist du hin und weg also ich
weiß nicht so ganz das klingt irgendwie
wie so ein spruch von irgendeinem
erwachsenen der so richtig auf krampf
versucht lustig zu sein oder
da bist du hin und weg naja solange die
konzer schmeckt sollte mir das egal sein
die kam erst vor zwei wochen raus und
zwar am ersten juni okay sind einige
schon vor drei wochen von das war die
letzte im kühlregal ich bin froh dass
ich sie bekommen haben dann haben wir zu
guter letzt eine wagner pizza und zwar
haben sie sich gedacht ich habe das
natürlich alles gegoogelt und mich
informiert da sind vier verschiedene
pizzen rausgekommen die alle den namen
von irgend einer europäischen stadt
tragen und dann halt auch mit diesen
zutaten die dort üblich sind belegt
wurden davon habe ich zwei gekauft
einmal die amsterdam mit gouda und käse
hätte man sich dann genau was zusätzlich
ist einfach lassen können und hier haben
wir noch die pizza ist dann wohl mit
chili peppers und wikis bin ich mal
gespannt wie die schmecken
ich will gar nicht lange lagern ich
würde sagen wir knallen direkt mal die
erste pizza im ofen und dann wenn ich
mal gespannt welche heute gewinnen gilt
also ich würde sagen wir starten mit
dieser hier ja was geht alles wird genau
das ist die pizza quattro firma die
leute bevor es losgeht zeige ich euch
mal eben noch ein trick den ich mal
benutzt der ist vor allem sehr wichtig
für leute die schon alleine wohnen oder
die einfach keinen bock darauf haben
irgendwelche sachen zu spielen gegen
welche teller zu benutzen wie ich zum
beispiel man mache die pizza auf und
jetzt wird man einfach folgendes zack
zack
und wie man sieht wir haben hier ein
perfektes stück das heißt wenn ihr
gefroren ist einfach kurz darauf bauen
dann bricht die perfekte ich habe schon
mal in den ofen jetzt brauchen wir
natürlich noch ein teller danach wie man
folgendes man reißt einfach den
pizzakarton auf dann klappen wir das
hier um damit das fett hier nicht
durchkommt durch den sturm und wir haben
einen perfekten teller man die piste
drauflegen kann also dafür jetzt schon
mal bitte 5006 danke die pizzen sind
soweit fertig ich habe jetzt halt von
jeder ein stück
gemacht weil mehr kann hier auch nicht
essen das hier ist jetzt die erste und
ich muss sagen sieht eigentlich aus wie
jede stinknormale narita pützer die ich
bis jetzt in meinem leben gesehen habe
[Musik]
man sieht auf jeden fall direkt das ist
eine tiefe variante ist und die sollte
er jetzt eigentlich mehrere sorten käse
beinhalten so weit ich weiß auch wenn
sie meiner meinung nach nicht extrem
käse aussieht richtig umso mehr nach
käse deswegen bin ich jetzt einfach mal
gespannt ob die schmeckt okay also da
habe ich eigentlich direkt schon mein
urteil ich schiebe das mal so cool
weiter wieso immer in diesen küchen
schoss so
[Musik]
auch gerecht ob jetzt ich finde sie
schmeckt gut sie schmeckt jetzt für mich
nicht neu also es ist jetzt nicht was
komplett neues habe ich schon
aufgegessen also halb pizzen die ähnlich
beziehungsweise gleich geschmeckt haben
meiner meinung nach also für mich
persönlich ist das schon ein bisschen zu
viel käse ich weiß dass leute schmecken
aber es trifft jetzt nicht zu 100
prozent meinen favorisierten
geschmackssache
deswegen gibt es auch hier von mir nur
sieben von zehn punkte aber halt nur
weil es so extrem käse schmeckt bis halt
meine persönliche meinung für die die
jetzt so gerne essen mit ganz viel käse
drauf und auch diesem intensiven käse
geschmack könnt euch die pizza kann ich
im film ok heute jetzt bin ich extrem
ausland bevor ich diese pizza probiere
muss ihr euch die erst mal zeigen wie
die aussieht und ich finde da sieht man
direkt dass das auf jeden fall einem
modell ist ein modell das hört sich
irgendwie solartechnik an ich will nur
wissen dass das hier auf jeden fall eine
prämie pizza schaut euch das mal an
ja der käse liegt hier so locker drüber
ich glaube nur der teig ist schon einmal
vor erhitzt worden der rest wurde per
hand wir hier draufsteht von hand
gemacht draufgelegt das ist in weiß
nicht aber was man sagen muss es sich
heftig aus und ich bin mal gespannt wie
es schmeckt das ist die vegetarische
pizza mit spinat von gustavo gusto oder
wie die heißen ich habe mir mal ganz
gemacht einfach weil ich fand dieser so
nice aus der wirtschaft gewesen sich ein
stück abzuschneiden und dies oft
ziemlich groß also die passt nicht mehr
auf dem teller
[Musik]
ich finde aber die sieht auf jeden fall
so aus wie eine pizza die man im
restaurant auf dem teller bekommt also
wenn wir jetzt gegen wir hinlegen würde
dann würde ich nicht ob ich das jetzt
als tiefkühlwaren identifizieren könnte
ich mit heute irgendwie übels schlauen
leischik unterarme mack und also dann
wollen wir mal mit messer und gabel wie
sich das ein restaurant gehört
also ich glaube ich habe alles was drauf
ist einmal gegessen und ich muss sagen
es schmeckt wirklich sehr gut und meine
vermutung was sich ja auch schon vom
optischen gedacht habe dass sie halt ein
bisschen mehr wie so eine pizza im
restaurant schmeckt hat sich auf jeden
fall bestätigt ich finde das ist mir
deutlich mehr nach einer richtigen
künstler wie man sie halt kennt sie
schmeckt ein bisschen frischer und auch
wenn ich jetzt nicht der riesen
spinatblätter bin für dich dem spinat
darauf in ordnung
deswegen gibt es familie neun von zehn
punkte kann man auf jeden fall essen ist
ein bisschen teurer auch als die anderen
aber probiert das mag ich feiert mega
und ich glaube die hole ich mir jetzt
läuft also daumen nach oben von mir den
pizza tester ok dann kommen wir zur
dritten pizza fürs heutige video das ist
die wagner pizza amsterdam auch 2009 10
[Musik]
hier ist auf jeden fall auch wieder
ähnlich wie bei der ersten wir haben
extrem viel käse und ob die mich jetzt
mehr überzeugt als die erste ich bin mal
gespannt sieht auf jeden fall ganz
lecker aus ist natürlich in diesem
amerikanischen stil so ein bisschen
dicker wir werden sehen
ok kann ich direkt schon zur seite
schieben schmeckt richtig richtig gut
hat mir sehr gut gefallen das einzige
was ich ein bisschen blöd finden ist ein
relikt der boden der extrem hoch ist
also wir haben ziemlich viel teig oder
ponys menge an käse obendrauf und dem
hohen boden der pizza falls man das so
nennt haben wir am ende eigentlich guten
gesamt geschmack den ich mit ab von 10
punkten benotet
also ist jetzt nicht besser als die
davor und jetzt bin ich wirklich mal
gespannt jetzt kommen wir zu letzten die
ist dann wohl pizza.de interessiert mich
eigentlich am meisten tuka wie schon
öfter mal gegessen brauchte den einen
oder anderen bekommen das ja türkei ein
oder anderen typischen freund da gibt es
dann zu hause also bis gleich so okay so
sieht's aus hier finden die direkt auf
wir haben viel mehr belag als auf allen
anderen plätzen pepperoni zwiebeln noch
irgendwas was ich nicht identifiziert
[Musik]
und dann würde ich auch hier mal sagen
ich weiß direkt mal rein
ich bin gespannt muss ich leider sagen
hatten ganz komischen beigeschmack geben
wie ich finde da ist ob zu viel drauf
also mich überzeugt dass gar nicht die
davor war viel besser also hier muss ich
leider sagen punkt geht nach amsterdam
der tube darauf sagt man bilde das stück
darauf ist auf jeden fall gut den rest
finde ich nicht gut
deswegen gibt es von mir auch nur lieb
gemeinte vier von zehn punkte also das
war auf jeden fall die schlechteste
meiner meinung nach ja also wenn ich
jetzt noch mal alles zusammenpasse
premium pizza lohnt sich auf jeden fall
mal ein bisschen mehr auszugeben
schmeckt wirklich frisch und wie beim
italiener wir das sehr gern selber gibt
mir dann nach oben und schreibt weitere
ideen für weitere passt dieses formats
in die kommentare
welche kategorie von lebensmitteln
solcher testen die neu auf dem markt
sind schreibt in die kommentare
oder schreiben wie instagram 30 alex wie
wir sehen uns morgen 19 uhr wieder
gibt's neues video und jetzt jeden tag
läuft nur haut rein